we touched on this in the video on
resonance but i want to devote an entire
video to aromatic compounds
aromatic
aeromatic
compounds
and one of the big mysteries in
chemistry is why they were named
aromatic compounds because you know it
clearly comes from the word aroma so one
would think maybe all of these compounds
smell good or smell bad or don't smell
at all but it actually turns out that a
lot of them don't even smell at all so
it's a little bit of a mystery some
people think that they have some
relation
the gentleman who named them saw that
they had some chemical relation to
things that did smell so that he named
them aromatic compounds so it is a bit
of a mystery in general the most common
aromatic compound and really this is
like 99 of the time what you're going to
see in chemistry class as an aromatic
compound is either benzene or a molecule
derived from benzene and let me draw
benzene right here so benzene is
normally
drawn like this
let me draw so it's a six carbon ring
and it has three double bonds
it has three double bonds like that and
we learned in the resonance video that
this isn't actually
the only configuration for benzene it
could just as likely be in this
configuration that this electron up here
this electron up here might move there
this electron might move over there and
then this electron might move over there
so let me clear that up so you don't
make it too confusing so it could just
as likely be in this configuration
it could just as likely be in
this configuration right here where the
double bonds are on the other are on the
other bonds that aren't that aren't
double bonded over here so it could just
as easily be over there and we learned
in the residence video that the reality
is it's actually in between
and sometimes it's drawn like this as
going back and forth between these
configurations but the reality and
you'll see sometimes you'll sometimes
see it drawn like this
you'll sometimes see it drawn like this
which is a circle in between in in the
middle of the the the hexane ring i
guess you could say or the benzene ring
the benzene ring which is showing that
the electrons those pi electrons those
electrons that form the double bond are
actually just they're going back and
forth between this they're just
spreading around the entire ring and
what makes aromatic compounds
interesting is because these pi
electrons can spread around the entire
ring that there it's actually a much
more stable configuration or a much more
stable molecule than what you would
predict if you just looked at one of
these two configurations and another way
you could another way that it's often
drawn looks something like this another
way and i'm just doing it in yellow just
to have something in a different color
sometimes you'll just see this that you
know someplace in between that and that
so you'll have a dotted line there
dotted line dotted line dotted line
dotted line dotted line this is the most
common kind of shorthand for showing
both a both benzene and for showing that
it's experiencing this resonance that
you have this conjugated system of pi
electrons and i'll help you visualize
that in a second but you also might see
it something like this it can be it can
go back and forth and everything in
between between these two configurations
now just to visualize what's going on
because you'll see sometimes here people
talk about conjugated system of pi
electrons i want to actually think about
think a little bit help a little bit
more visualizing what the molecule might
look like in three dimensions
what it might look like in three
dimensions so that is
the six carbon ring right there so it's
carbon
carbon carbon carbon
carbon carbon
and then each of these carbons is bonded
to three other atoms responded to
one two carbons and it's also bonded to
a hydrogen so let me draw the hydrogens
here so they're also bonded to hydrogen
so this one will have a hydrogen over
here this will have a hydrogen over here
that will have a hydrogen over there
that one has a hydrogen over there
hydrogen
and hydrogen right over there
so if you we talk about hybridization we
have three hybridized orbitals this is
sp2 hybrid hybridization and each of
these have a leftover pi orbital that
has not been hybridized it's not
directly bound to or that does not have
a sigma bond to another to another atom
so you have these pi orbitals and you
know these pi orbitals look like these
dumbbells
so you have a pi orbital over here you
have a pi orbital over here
pi orbital over here
pi orbital
over there
you have another pi orbital over there
pi orbital and pi orbital and you know
pi over i drew them like this because if
i draw them bigger than that the diagram
would get messy but in general whenever
you have double bonds like this double
bond let's say that this carbon let me
change colors so we know what we're
focused on so let's say this sigma bond
right over there let's say that that
sigma bond right over there is this
sigma bond actually let me do another
one just so it's easier to see
let's say that this sigma bond right
over here is this sigma bond between
these two carbons this double bond
the double bond in blue this one or in
purple right over there that's due to
these overlapping pi orbitals that
carbon's pi orbitals and that carbon's
pi orbitals overlapping i haven't drawn
them overlapping but well actually an
electron can really show up it's all
probabilistic anyway but i could draw
them big enough they would overlap and
these electrons would form that extra pi
bond
what happens in a conjugated system of
pi electrons let me write that down so
it's a very fancy word
conjugated
conjugated
system
system
of
of pi and let me write well you can you
have pi
electrons
conjugated system of pi electrons
these guys as we see they could be
bonded with each other these guys could
overlap
so there could be an overlap going on
over here or we could flip into this
configuration where this guy would
overlap with this guy over here and the
reality is that these pi electrons will
actually be able to float around the
ring they'd actually be able to float
around all of these pi orbitals right
over there they'd actually be able to
float around the ring so that's what
people are really talking about when
they talk about aromatic con compounds
or aromaticity that because of this this
is a more stable compound the most
typical one you're going to see is a six
carbon chain with three double bonds
benzene or things derived from them but
there actually are more general ones in
general you're going to see anything
that has 4n plus 2
four and
plus two
pi electrons
pi electrons in a cycle
is going to have aromaticity or it's
going to be an aromatic
aromatic
compound so just
let's just confirm this actually makes
it so each of these guys have
each of these guys over here have one pi
electron even though this looks like
kind of two bonds remember this is one
this is one pi orbital right over here
and you have one electron that's going
to be in this entire pi orbital so this
has one pi electron two three four five
six another way to think about it each
of these double bonds involves two pi
electrons so one two
three four five six so that follows what
is called huckles rule
that follows what is called huckel's
rule
huckel's rule i think there's two dots
above the u who houghl's rule maybe
that follows huckle's rule because if
you set n is equal to 1 4 times 1 is 4
plus 2 is 6. so 6 pi electrons work if n
was 2 you'd have 4 times 2 plus 2 which
is 10. so if you had 10 pi electrons it
would also work so a molecule that looks
like this
let me see if i can draw it a molecule
that looks like this would also work so
if you have 1
seven
eight
nine
ten
ten
carbons and then you had five double
bonds so one
two
three
four
five just like that you can imagine
these guys could flip around but this
would also be an aromatic compound this
has 10 pi electrons each of the carbons
have a pi electron or you could count
the pi electrons on each end of these pi
bonds one two three four five six
seven eight
nine ten now this is one thing that i
always wonder it's like okay it worked
with six it worked with ten but what
about eight it seems like with eight you
could maybe these electrons these double
bonds could flip around just as easily
so what if i had
what if i had or even four what if i had
a molecule that looked like this
would have had a molecule that looked
like this or a molecule that looked like
a stop sign so one two three four five
six seven eight that had double bonds
that alternated like this you might say
hey maybe those also are aromatic
compounds those also experience
aromaticity because couldn't this guy
jump around here and then that guy over
there and the electrons cycle around or
this guy jump over these electrons move
there those move there those move there
and those move there and it turns out
that in these compounds it's actually
there's it the the electrons do not the
pi electrons do not stabilize the system
that this is actually less stable than
it was not in a cycle so actually this
is
these right here that don't follow the
4n plus 2. so 4n plus 2 you're talking
about 6
10
14
pi electrons which usually means 14
carbons or 10 carbons or 6 carbons
the ones that don't follow them but are
still cyclical and still have these
alternating bonds these are called
anti-aromatic these are anti-aromatic
aromatic and are actually very unstable
these are very
very unstable and are more likely to
break into a non-cycle anyway hopefully
you found that vaguely useful